hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we just
landed on the planet here and that
already doesn't look very good
oh here's one of the motors to get the
marker off the shuttle okay baby you got
it baby
oh you so fine when we go over this I'm
gonna take you all the best romantic
dinner okay but what were you pointing
loader offline loader offline do you
expect me to do it it's offline there's
blood everywhere always always good sign
you said this is gonna be a nice
vacation
looks like crap I know baby
you actually real some crazy psycho huh
oh no my gun went right through you
oh it's good oh okay I gotta get this
this and take it to somewhere
go somewhere else and then do something
- ever - whatever she tells me - I must
obey must obey here we go there it
turned off yes dude thumb
how did that automatically get out of
the shuttle I don't know it don't matter
logic doesn't play a factor yeah
yep
that's pretty good I'm sure those flimsy
metal beams could hold up that entire
rather light looking marker oh I push it
yeah okay you just stay over there honey
I'll do all the heavy lifting gear
sweetiepie sugar cake dumpling sugar
Lumpkin
fanny pack
Sally sue
ah Brunello
let me get a good look II got dirt on
your face big disgrace got blood on your
leg how did you survive doesn't make any
sense I don't matter you so fine here we
go
there we go Kalwa Oh goodies
goodie okay now what now what oh okay
really where do I get one in here in
here
don't don't have enemies lady oh boy
more suiciders whoa oh the marker needs
to be returned to the pedestal chamber
okay why the motor to bring it there and
place it on the pestle replacement we've
taken Omega Cola ghin yeah you keep
saying that I'm not sure I trust you I
sir just that bad hanging
bad care if you wanted to live too bad
oh this is a battery oh here we go
Godin got it honey sugarplum we're gonna
eat good tonight something none may
Altman be with you that yeah church
services twice weekly okay with door yay
okay nothing gonna ambush me whispers or
whispers Emma Skye omen why is the
contact energy this is out of sync that
annoys me I invented them annoying gun
get some pulse rounds up into y'all I'll
buy more lessons in distinction
I will try out all the weapons offenses
now pulse rounds I probably bought too
much there oh you can never have too
many pulse rounds right am i right yeah
okay
how am i doing I'm going I don't care
I'm looking around here oh that's not
good guys hanging from the ceiling this
is sergeant Newman below we walk all the
shuttles one of them just took off it
came straight back down and crashed into
the bay took a couple hundred people and
all the remaining shuttles with it if
anyone should hear this do not land you
not planned you should have heeded that
warning oh man this is you pair
alright there's nothing here okay got
the battery honey off contact energy
I've got the battery fearest
nowhere
where was where was Nicole okay she's
definitely not not really here or
totally crazy all-big hallucination
she's just disappeared
phenomenal yeah she's not real no way no
way all right I'll go with my crazy task
we're just disappearing in a monster
popping up camp
oh it's just
all right let's go making my way
downtown
Oh
oh let me
all of them
damaging your precious
there we this looked good news stasis
thank you caught on
well it's caught on a bridge my way
go support unknown fire forms detected
in the area security has identified at
least is the same computer from before I
see vents blown out up
hello surgical baby dead gone huh buddy
today ever
Oh easy
you try jumping up
what
this point in you you're such a failure
there we go there we go
all dead all done cut you look good ease
now okay cut that yeah I don't even know
your stations
oops more goodies let me spit each item
alright let's go buddy
oh that's okay hope I didn't damage your
precious
got scheduled the cave thought I saw now
come on now yo al ah hello
one more you're late to the party boy
your friends are dead that's too bad
oh what's that
- else anybody anybody Bueller Bueller
I saw yep
ah rubies semiconductor mmm more credits
for me and I saw this yep power lock Oh
give me the hell what the hell what are
you wait but I put it put put put but I
put it I put I put it in
oh stop dropping tool how bad I am
let's do it y-yeah that's real smart
across the walls come here
dr. Railly
now the quarantine is lifted oh thank
you thank you so much for that
oh is that door open now is the the
power node lock open
yes yes here we go Kevin some goodies
yay goodies goodies oh yes
okay didn't see any pyranose ready all
right it was probably worth more than
one card Oh
I'm guessing okay Open Sesame kicked it
off the counter potato potato potato
ah hey prepare through
Oh
we go there we go there we go there we
go there we go all right on not another
baby baby skewers oh man
other two of them Filatova it
get out damn it
okay I got this
oh damn it
goddammit die die okay I think that
one's dead
when he switched to the contact beam
hide in my little corner here and let
that off you want to live too bad
why can't I have a fire stick
- you're on it
died good job boom alright switch to the
good old gun womp womp it I'm watching
pompous
Wampus fiddly dumpling this bridge
working was not working
how do I need to go in there why why I
asked you why explained me why
OOP lockers hello give me coming okay
I've had a theory I saw this guy right
here it's this guy like a precursor to
those things because they're both
growing on the walls and they're both
kind of people ish cuz this guy's gonna
wake up and be like oh reach out with my
attendant yep there goes he's got
tentacles coming out of his chest
I think he's like the beginning stages
of one of those guys so I secured you
long it's gonna do without your head
nothing you're still alive nope yeah I
think he I think is
that makes sense often saves this Duke
Duke Duke Duke Duke Duke all right now
why do I need to go here why are the
bridge control down whose star gets drop
off some of my goodies all right I don't
need that many
semiconductors good on that stuff
lots of plasma already that one weird
contact energy sticking in between any
of my viewers who are OCD real Burke
about that but I don't know all right
I'll fix it for you I'll fix it for you
hey I'll move it and then I'll get it
back that'll fix it yep that fixed it
okay all right that's all the time I got
for this episode thank you guys so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next part
bye bye